what i'd like to do in this video is
talk about the major schools of buddhism
as it is practiced today and can be
broadly divided into theravada buddhism
which means school of the elder monks
and mahayana buddhism which means great
vehicle maha for great
so first on the commonalities
now both of these schools of buddhist
thought or buddhist tradition believe in
this notion of the cycle of birth and
rebirth from one life or one reality to
the next that we call samsara which is
also shared with the core of hindu
philosophy and this idea that your goal
should be to realize that all is thought
to escape from the dukkha and eventually
obtain nirvana
now the difference between the two
schools of thought in theravada buddhism
it is
much closer to some of the original
practices or teachings that we see with
siddhartha gautama buddha that is a very
personal journey
that is all about the individual through
meditation perhaps with some help from
some teacher recognizing the non-self
recognizing that we are all one and
eventually either in this life or in
future lives achieving nirvana
now mahayana buddhism
actually encompasses a very large set of
various practices but the general idea
is that you might have help as you try
to achieve nirvana
someone who achieves nirvana is known as
an arhath
so you could view theravada buddhism as
hey try to go on this personal journey
to become an arhath to achieve nirvana
but in mahayana buddhism the pursuit is
not necessary to get to nirvana as
quickly as possible is to get close to
nirvana but then help others
try to achieve that same state
so the real goal is to be a bodhisattva
bodhisattva now the word bodhisattva is
used in both traditions in theravada
buddhism it's referred to someone who is
trying to become an arhat someone who is
on the path to achieving nirvana in
mahayana buddhism it is someone who has
almost achieved nirvana but holds that
off in order to help the rest of
sentient reality the rest of sentient
beings eventually achieve nirvana and if
you aren't one of the bodhisattvas you
have that help not only from
bodhisattvas but there's a fairly large
grouping of celestial beings that are
there to help that are there to help
focus your meditation and your energy
and what you see here is a depiction
that's not atypical from a mahayana
buddhist shrine in the middle here you
have amitabha buddha
and a significant chunk of mahayana
buddhis
believe in amitabha buddha and
you could view him as someone as revered
or as almost a deity like figure and
this idea that by visualizing by
focusing by invoking amitabha buddha
that you can get to his pure land of
bliss known as
sukhavati
and so this idea of almost a kind of
salvation that by focusing on amitabha
you get to this pure land of bliss which
is a place where it is easier to achieve
nirvana from and you can almost view it
as something of heaven now it's
interesting is amitabha buddha isn't
exactly the same figure as siddhartha
gautama buddha in some traditions
siddhartha gautama buddha is a
projection of amitabha into our reality
and in some mahayana belief systems
there are multiple realities each with
their own buddha and you can be born and
reborn into these different realities
and the pure land the pure land of
blissed the sukhavati is where you might
want to go if you are following if you
are practicing this belief in amitabha
buddha so at a very high level daravatha
buddhism is all about this personal
journey trying to follow in the
practice of siddhartha gautama buddha
through meditation through recognizing
the four noble truths by following the
middle way getting eventually in this
life and in future lives to nirvana
becoming an arhat
mahayana buddhism has a more complex
pantheon of celestial beings and deities
and it can be diverse from one part of
the world to another eventually the goal
is for all sentient beings to achieve
nirvana but your individual goal can be
better described as delaying nirvana
becoming a bodhisattva and assisting all
other sentient beings and achieving that
nirvana these are actually the attendant
bodhisattvas on the left and the right
of amitabha buddha but you don't have
just the help of the bodhisattvas but
there's also celestial beings things
that you can focus on things that you
can invoke to eventually help you get to
that
now
nirvana
order to see where it is practiced we
have this map right over here first of
all most of buddhism is practiced in the
far east of asia or southeast asia and
you see the various schools of buddhism
so in red here you have the theravada
the school of the elder monks
in yellow here you have mahayana the
great vehicle and in orange you have
vajrayana a significant chunk of
vajrayana buddhis are often referred to
as tibetan buddhist and they're
sometimes grouped with the mahayana it's
closer to mahayana there's this notion
of bodhisattvas there are celestial
beings there are more rituals
now in terms of population the country
with the largest buddhist population is
china roughly 250 million buddhists of
the 500 million buddhists that there are
in the world but despite the fact that
there are so many buddhists in china it
is still only 18 of the entire chinese
population
in places like burma and thailand you
have a much higher percentage of the
population that is actually buddhist in
these regions of southeast asia most of
the population is buddhist now one other
really interesting thing about this map
is we talk about buddhism starting in
northeast india and southern nabahal
that's where siddhartha gautama buddha
lived that's where he spread his
teachings and not only is that where it
originated you have ashoka who really
catalyzed the spread of buddhism and
once again that was out of india but
when you look at this demographic map of
where you have significant buddhist
groupings you don't see a lot in india
you see a lot in sri lanka and that's
actually where the theravada tradition
comes primarily from and there's a
couple of interesting explanations for
why you don't see it in india
one possible explanation is that it was
so close to many versions of hindu
practice and we talk about hinduism as
being this very diverse and open
religion that it really just got
re-absorbed reassimilated as part of the
diverse hindu tradition in fact many
hindus view buddha as another
incarnation of visnu